est ce qu'ils peuvent essayer de le
faire à partir du but pour voir s'ils le
mettent à partir du 8 venez là on y va
[Musique]
non hier il a croisé celle là bruno est
meilleur que le mec qui fixe j'adore tes
chômage
j'adore tes saut m'a dit vas-y
je hais les maximes et c'est je le mets
sur la tête de ma mère
j'entre une voiture à toute l'écurie
faire comme avant deux ou trois de ces
il est tout puissant vous l'avez us à la
caméra la reprise de ballons chauds
[Musique]
supporters annuler vos idées
les mac d'oc personnes la nuit audison
l'actionnaire à la foule ont fait chacun
leur tour
c'est comme ça m ils font face à troyes
tard une fois comme ça vous êtes tkc
jobin les bains si vous vous êtes avec
nous allez sa défaite j'ai compris il
faut que le mètre de plus mais pas comme
ça excuse moi tu écris ta mère ouais
c'est le premier kilo mais si vous êtes
avec nous attention c'est parti
la deuxième partie de soirée t'inquiète
perron t'inquiète je le mets soit c'est
le dernier
[Rires]
le dernier c'est le dernier elle te
provoque il en bouche c'est le dernier
qui n'a pas bien
basit à la base il aimait crois pas à
ces inventaires la lega c'est le dernier
sa cassure et au retrait maisons ont
narré nniversaire les gars ça ne sert il
devient gênant qu'un pôle provost a bien
attaqué ils sont très forts son inaction
très forte luminance et les joggings
jogging non et oui oui oui
brad est allé battre cette année c'est
le dernier
ça fait car il est le dernier clou
dernier le monde parce que moi je le met
pas à pas si ça c'est un peu ce genre
arrive en avant des arguments la ville
de mossoul
sauvé nérac ballon moi ça ne me dit pas
d'accord tu me fais bien des choses moi
ok tu parles non c'est n'a pas ça c'est
pas tout en sachant je te reconnais pas
cyril s'est révélé 21h16 les chefs ou
quatre occupants des chalets à salvador
à gaza du jouet remercier les alertes
des potters qui avaient tous merci
surtout londres a pour eux ils sont très
très fortes gelées qui dit non j'ai
compris que je n'étais pas
on est moins bons éléments fixes et
j'avais pas l'autre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le dernier bye s attention faire